وتنورنا في الاستوديو زميلتنا العزيزه في
قناه العربيه ميسون العزام ميسون اهلا بك
رمضان كريم نورتنا الله اكرم كل عام وانتم
بخير ينعاد عليكم شكرا والله
شكرا للعربيه واحنا نقول شكرا العربيه
وشكرا لك على هالتقرير حلو على هالمبادرات
الحلوه شكرا لالكم انه منصه العربيه كانت
دائما فاتحه ابوابها للمبادرات الانسانيه
الخامسه بدات انسانيه ولمده خمس سنين ممكن
ازعم انه كانت
النشره الاخباريه الوحيده بالعالم العربي
اليوميا تتطرق الى الجانب الانساني وهي
رسالتنا اعتقد بالعربيه طيب اعطني من وقتك
ميسون حدثيني عن هالمبادره الجديده هلا
الاسم كاتي من وقتك لانه كتير ناس بسالوني
من منين بتجيب الوقت يا ميسون لانه تعمل
كثير مبادرات تتذكروا وعملنا برمضان
الماضي مبادره اكرمهم تكرمني وطلعت هالمره
بهاي المبادره من وقتك لانه الوقت جدا
ثمين وهو الوقت اللي عندي هو نفسه اللي
عندك ولكن كيف تستثمر هذا الوقت فانا
بحاول ابعت رساله الناس انه انت باي طريقه
ممكن تستثمر هذا الوقت وخاصه للجانب
الانساني انا اؤمن انه يمكن فرض واسقاط
الجانب الانساني بحياتك كلها ان كان
بالعمل مثل ما عملت يعني كان عندي استضافه
بمسائل العربيه قلت بس ليش ما اطفي عليها
الجانب الانساني ببيتك بحياتك كل شيء طيب
ميسون انا كمان بدي استفيد من الوقت وقت
المقابله يعني التقرير كان جميل جدا
واستمتعنا بمشاهدته وبهذه المبادرات بس
انا كمان لفت لي نظري هذا التوب الجميل
اللي لابستيه من الاجواء كمان الرمضانيه
اليوم لو تحكيلنا كمان عنه لانه اول مره
بنشوف ميسون على الشاشه بلوك مختلف انا
لابسه ثوب فلسطيني طبعا ما بعرف اذا
الشاشه الكبيره ممكن تفرجينا اياها توب
فلسطيني
من بئر السبع هذا التوب عمره اكثر من 80
سنه
في رسائل يعني انت لما تكوني باي منطقه
بفلسطين وتشوفي ثوب وحده لابسته بتعرفي من
اي منطقه بتعرفي اذا كانت مجوزه او مش
مجوزه بتعرفي اذا كانت مجوزه ويمكن رجعت
تطلقت او كانت ارمله الى اخرها فكل رسائل
موجوده مثل البرغع البراقع كمان بفلسطين
وهول من بير السبع وكمان عمرهم اكثر من 90
سنه يمكن هول من مقتنيات اللي انا جمعتها
فبركع بكون بتعرفي انه المراه عزابيه او
لا وواحد بتعرفي انه هي مجوزه اضافه والله
بعدني انت بدك
وبعدين العملات الموجوده هي مهر البنت
وطبعا بيعكس وضع الاجتماعي ووضع اهلها
كمان نفس الوقت
في كثير منهم متفاجئوا في كثير منهم اه
كثير حلوه وعجبتهم الفكره
الجميل انه مطعم سانسيشن وضع نفس الاموال
اللي انا حصلت عليها بهذا اليوم نفس
المبلغ وضعه زياده فقدرنا بالنهايه انه
نكسل خمس ايتام بفلسطين وهاي شيء جميل
بالمقابل تبنى المبادره ايضا فرح يصير
يعملها دائما مع شخصيات مختلفه اعطي من
وقتك
وبنفس الوقت لما كنت موجوده كان في صبيه
كمان قالت انا بدي
بيسكلي كمان بتمنى انه اشوف ان شاء الله
اشوفكم هلا بس بدي اقول شغله انه ما حدا
بحياته يقول انه شغلي اصعب شغل بالعالم
لانه اشتغلت بالمطعم ما كانت سهله لانه
بتتعاملي مع ناس كثير فتره الافطار الناس
كلها بدها نفسها وبدها معدتها فبحاول
الواحد مع ابتسامه مع رمضان كريم انه
يقدمها يروح عن الناس وهيك ولكن الحمد لله
كانت تيم كثير داعم لالي وطبعا الزملاء
باسل وسامر من العربيه كانوا معي كانوا
كمان صايمين طبعا ميه بالميه
[ضحك]